الانتظار المرهق اليائس للحصول على
الوعد بحياة جديدة في أوروبا، هؤلاء
الباكستانيون محشورون في غرفة صغيرة من قبل
المهربين في ليبيا، ويعتقد
أن بعضهم من بين المئات الذين يُفترض أنهم لقوا حتفهم،
هذه الصور الأخيرة قبل الشروع
في رحلتهم المشؤومة حوالي 750
لاجئًا  وكان المهاجرون مكتظين في
سفينة الصيد هذه المتجهة إلى إيطاليا
قبل أن تنقلب قبالة سواحل
اليونان، ولم ينج
سوى مائة وأربعة مهاجرين
ومعهم الروايات المروعة عما
مروا به، ولا
أزال أستطيع سماع صوت امرأة
تنادي من أجلهم.  مساعدتك على السباحة
ونقل الجثث العائمة بعيدًا عن طريقك.
تحدث إلينا ناجٍ سوري من
اليونان وطلب إخفاء هويته لأسباب
أمنية.
ولا تتعارض رواياته وغيرها التي حصلت عليها CNN مع
الرواية اليونانية الرسمية
للأحداث فحسب، بل تشير أيضًا إلى أن  بسبب خطأ
خفر السواحل اليوناني، تصر السلطات اليونانية
التي شاهدت القارب وكانت على اتصال
به لمدة يوم كامل على
أنه لم يكن في محنة ورفضت
المساعدة، ويروي تحقيقنا
قصة مختلفة
تمامًا قبل الساعة الواحدة ظهرًا يوم 13 يونيو، القارب
تم رصده لأول مرة من قبل
وكالة حرس الحدود التابعة للاتحاد الأوروبي (فرونتكس) التي قالت إنها
أخطرت السلطات اليونانية
بسفينة صيد مكتظة للغاية وكان
من على متنها في محنة فقدوا في
البحر دون طعام أو ماء لعدة أيام
وفقًا للناجين والناشطين الذين كانوا على
اتصال بالقارب طوال الوقت.
في حوالي الساعة 7 مساءً من اليوم، سجل ناشط في إيطاليا
إحدى المكالمات التي تصور
الرعب على متن القارب
[ضحك]
حيث قام النشطاء مرارًا وتكرارًا بنقل دعوات
الإنقاذ إلى السلطات
للسفن التجارية التي تقترب من القارب الذي طلب منه
خفر السواحل اليوناني تزويد
القارب بالمساعدة.  الطعام والماء
ولكن مع حلول الظلام في الساعة 10:40 مساءً على
سفينة خفر السواحل اليونانية، تتحرك الآن
السفينة الوحيدة في مكان الحادث بعد ثلاث ساعات.
الكلمات الأخيرة المؤرقة من
القارب إلى هاتف إنذار مجموعة النشطاء
مرحبًا يا صديقي، السفينة التي ترسلها هي
و  من المرجح أن يثير قطع الخط ما حدث بعد ذلك
المزيد من الأسئلة مع
استمرار التحقيقات.
أخبرنا الناجون أن محاولة فاشلة من قبل
خفر السواحل اليوناني لسحب قاربهم هي التي
تسببت في انقلابه،
فقرروا رميه كحبل حتى يتمكن
الرجال من  ربطته المقدمة وأخبرونا أن
القارب يميل إلى اليمين وكان
الجميع يصرخون وبدأ الناس
يسقطون في البحر
وانقلب القارب ولم يتمكن الناس من الخروج من
تحت القارب، رفض خفر السواحل اليوناني
طلبنا لإجراء
مقابلة ولكن في  التعليقات السابقة التي
أنكروا سحب العربة قائلين
عندما انقلب القارب لم نكن حتى
بجواره، كيف يمكننا سحبها
بدلاً من ذلك، ألقوا باللوم على التحول في
الوزن ربما بسبب الذعر
هنا، وقد اتُهمت السلطات اليونانية
بالدفع بشكل منهجي وعنيف  فيديو عودة المهاجرين واللاجئين
مثل هذا الذي نشرته
الحكومة التركية يصور
الممارسة الموثقة جيدًا الآن. تنفي اليونان أن
هذا الحادث المميت لا يتعلق فقط
بما ربما فعلوه، بل أيضًا
بما لم يفعلوه، كان من الواضح أنه
لم يتم رؤيته  الجدير بالذكر أنه كان من الواضح
أنها جزء من حركة تهريب
أه من ليبيا إلى أوروبا لذا
تقع على عاتق السلطات مسؤولية
التدخل لإنقاذ الحياة حيث
تشدد قلعة أوروبا سياساتها المتعلقة بالهجرة
لردع بعض الفئات الأكثر
ضعفًا في العالم. هذه الكارثة شبه
مؤكدة  لن يكون الأخير شامانا
كراتشي سي إن إن لندن